so let's go with the most important
thing looking back now it's been a few
months did you have fun at Comic-Con
with me or was it a bad experience do
you want to know the truth I do want to
know the truth okay so the way Comic Con
works as you well know right is you go
down some elevators or escalators or
whatever it was to get to whole H and
you also kept like away from the
audience the whole time you went
backstage
and so the last chance to go to the
restroom is like a real maze like I was
wondering if you're gonna see this story
go on no no and so it was like
I don't know why I did it but someone
gave me a big bottle of water and I
drank the Whole Bowl I don't know if
there's nerves or something but I drank
the entire bottle and I suddenly went
downstairs and I thought I'll just go to
pee just before we go on and then we go
to go on and um and there's no restroom
anywhere and it's like three two one
Gareth Edwards go you know what I mean
and I sat there I'm not joking I'm
really not joking I sat there and I
can't I was like I'm gonna pee myself
and we were there for what it was an
hour and a half yeah it was 90 minutes
yeah and I was like I can't do this I
can't stay up here and I looked I
actually at one point actually looked to
see what what the audience could see of
my trousers
because and there was like you had it
you had a barrier thing up you did yes
because I was like I think I'm just
gonna pee myself
and like I wanted wanted to know how in
like career rendering it it would be if
I did so I do remember backstage you
saying to me uh I need to use the
bathroom and I was explaining to you
then you need to go all the way into the
convention thing or back upstairs and I
didn't realize the severity of it but
the highlight of everything though was
uh we went to play your footage from the
Creator the sizzle and uh all of you
guys went to use the bathroom I've never
seen a whole panel go to the bathroom
but Louie ended up I think he skipped it
and sat in the front row to watch the
footage but I was on stage alone yeah I
was gonna go when Justin's clip played
of uh Haunted Mansion and I really
wanted to pee then and I was like it's
gonna look so rude if I if this clip
plays and I just run off stage and so
like I had to just take it and then my
clip came up and I was like I can go now
right but the thing is you dream of
having a clip in whole H right that's
like your dream and I was just a urinal
hearing a echo through the urinals as
some guy was wearing with a rogue one
post that like awkwardly for me to sign
after I finished peeing and it was like
this is and it was like this is so
typical of filmmaking you know this is
how it all plays out yeah I think we all
I mean everyone knew you were going to
the bathroom I think or maybe not it
doesn't matter so I want to first of all
thank you for sharing the story because
I wasn't sure if you were gonna anyway
um but one of the things that's amazing
about this movie is the fact that you
basically uh I think you radically
changed how movies can be made and what
might happen in the future with the way
you shot this and the fact that you
didn't design certain things before you
went to location can you sort of talk
about the like it's pretty radical way
you shot this yeah because one on what
normally happens is
you you know you have this fantasy about
a movie you want to make and you have
all these designers and concept artists
and you kind of figure out the world
and it looks great and everything and
then you go okay how are we gonna do
this and everyone's chasing that image
okay well if you want this sort of shape
you have to build that and if you want
this sort of environment we can't go
this we're gonna we'll do that against
green screen and and it all sort of
becomes like a 200 million dollar movie
and never feels as good and so it was
like look it let's do this the other way
around right let's go make the film so
let's go to wherever in the world it's
the best location possible like if you
have the crew small enough
then the cost of going any flying
anywhere in the world with that group of
people is cheaper than building a set
like the second it's a bigger crew now
it's more expensive and so let's just
build a set right so it was like get
that down so we can go anywhere and then
and then it's like let's shoot the movie
Let's edit it and then when we know
what's in the film let's give those
frames to our designer James Klein and
his team and they they can paint in the
science fiction of exactly what's in the
movie so it's like a way more efficient
thing and it also then meant you can
blend in whatever happy accident you had
in the real world or crazy location you
found just randomly you can then like
base your designs on like what what the
foreground looks like and what the mid
ground looks like and and so it's it's
way better all around and I wouldn't go
back personally to the other way what I
was going to say is this like a is this
a permanent change to the way you're
going to make movies going forward yeah
I think I mean I think you could push it
even further like I yeah definitely I
wouldn't I wouldn't go back to the other
way of making it it's so interesting
because I've spoken to some people who
basically it's it's crazy that the
technology has reached this point where
you can do this because in the past I
was always I guess I wasn't under the
assumption that with VFX it was more you
couldn't do it yeah and I think that is
the Assumption even with VFX people and
so
we so what happened was we
we talked about this process with
industrialized magic and
and they're you know obviously
everyone's like nodding but thinking oh
my God what is what we getting ourselves
into and so we did a little test and we
didn't tell the studio but they gave us
some money
uh to go on a location scout and so we
went to
Tokyo Nepal
um Cambodia Vietnam Thailand Indonesia
and we shot it's crazy I know we just
wanted a holiday right and I took a
camera with me that had like a 1970s
anamorphic lens and shot a little I
don't know what you'd call it little
taster teaser short nonsense thing and
then essentially basically tried to sort
of prove this Theory and do exactly what
we do on the movie and give it to ilm
didn't have any tracking markers or dots
or any data or any silver balls and all
those things you see just give it them
that all they had was the footage and
went can you figure this out they went
away and you know I wouldn't say It's
Magic because I met some of them
recently I think one of the guys was
called Tim I said I'd shout and give him
a shout out
um but through a lot of Blood Sweat and
Tears they got that
they managed to track all that stuff
back into the computer and
um
and pulled it off and I think they were
even surprised and so they were like so
we're like can we do the movie like this
then and they were like yeah actually
that was pretty stuff that would
normally take
like a month to do we were doing in like
a couple of days or so and like in terms
of building cities we didn't build the
cities we just projected them back onto
footage and all this sort of stuff and
so we showed that to the studio
and they had like for the money we'd
done it for they were like oh if you can
make a movie like that we're in and so
we got green lit basically are you
planning are you uh are you ready for
the lessons you're going to be giving at
like the DGA to other directors on how
you pulled this off no they didn't want
to hear from me I have a feeling that
there's going to be a lot of people that
want to learn uh because it it's a lot
cheaper to do it the way you do it did
it than the other way it's it's radical
yeah you know what was funny though is
like when we were when I was prepping
the film or not even prepping it I was
just kind of curious about certain
technology and went to there's a studio
in La that does the whole virtual um
volume stuff
and just as I was waiting there was a
poster on the wall and it was basically
the process of making a film it was like
a venn diet I don't know what it was it
was like a diagram of this is how a
movie is made and it was this is you
write the script it does this and these
are all the different people and and I
was looking at the poster going
okay why have they got this poster on
the wall like it's so obvious this is
like filmmaker what's this about and the
guy who came up to me and went oh I see
you're looking at the poster and I was
like yeah he goes um that's over 100
years old and I was like what and then
you realize in over a century we've not
changed a thing do you mean like the
idea that something so technological so
digital now is a hundred year old
process like it it it you know there's
got to be an easier way a better way of
doing this stuff but it's like it's some
Factory and it just doesn't want to
change you know what I mean let me
switch to something completely different
I want to make sure I say the name right
uh Hank Corwin yes is your editor yes uh
and like talk a little bit about working
with him because this is a radically
different way of making a movie so did
you have like a longer cut like how did
it work with the editing when you're
doing VFX I guess talk a little bit
about working with them so yeah so Hank
so so basically so Joe Walker did the
assembly who edited soon and such
amazing films and uh Hank and and Scott
Morris basically were the two editors on
the movie and Hank
if you be prior to the making this movie
if you had said to me Gareth what's the
two best edited films in the history of
Cinema I would have gone I can't answer
that question because I'm torn between
JFK and the Tree of Life
and uh they have an editor in common
which is Hank call in and he's just kind
of a bit of a genius and so
um we we essentially ended up in the
situation where Hank was always like he
had done big movies but he hadn't done
like as with as many VFX shots as we had
in this and and and so but it didn't
matter because all we did is we
basically cut the movie and one of the
things they didn't have to worry about
is everything There Was Always Something
There representing what was going to be
the effects so in a lot if I think it
would have been a nightmare if we'd shot
one of these films where it was green
screen or blue screen sure but because
it was like we really were in the
jungles and the Himalayas and so there's
even if there wasn't the Sci-Fi Temple
there was a Temple and so you could just
cut this like uh a contemporary film and
so and what they were so good at is like
Hank what I love about him he does many
many things but
um he's very left field with his
thinking I'm usually the person with a
rope trying to drag everyone else off a
cliff and everyone else is going no
Gareth no you're not mean and I'm like
come on let's get to the edge and
they're like we're gonna die right Hank
Hank lives he's got a house at the
bottom of the canyon like he's off he's
off the cliff already he's pulling me
and I'm going no Hank no you know like
and so it's like really refreshing to be
in a situation where someone is
challenging you creatively like making
you way out of your comfort zone and and
so that was beautiful and then
um and then there was only a few times I
remember quite a few conversations but
it wasn't like difficult but
I would go away and make selects because
obviously it's like okay I will you know
you is one of these jet copter things is
it coming in from the left or the right
or four and I'd be like I don't know I
just grabbed a load of footage and and
let's figure it out so I would sit and
try and figure out what I wanted to
happen and maybe drag some silly little
font across the screen to represent
where some CG you know vehicle might be
and then we would sit and watch like
eight or nine selects and talk about
them and
and you always want feedback you always
want you always want someone to like
agree with you you're not mean and and
so we
we had this really nice relationship
between the three of us where
um we kept each other like we pushed
each other but kept kept each other in
check and and
there was we it was to them I would
think they would say that it was like
doing a normal film in terms of the way
they cut it but
I know they really enjoyed sitting in on
the VFX
um conversations so when we talked to
ilm and we did all those zooms and stuff
they would be listening in because they
just were curious about how it all works
but it didn't
you didn't need to have like a PhD in
visual effects to cut this movie it was
because it was all there it was very we
didn't do green screen and things like
that so it was all quite straightforward
I butchered the original question so
I'll ask this one I like asking this of
every director did you have a much
longer cut is it like uh like did you
have a cut that you were like it's two
and a half hours I don't know how it's
getting down yeah the first cut was just
under five hours
so wait what the assembly I don't
generally hear assembly Cuts being five
hours it was it was under five hours
um it was yeah so Joe Joe Walker and yob
had done this cut of the movie whilst I
was shooting
and and then I and then they had to go
and do june two or Joe went to do june
2. and and so I went around Hank's house
and we basically he basically hit play
on this like
just under five hour cut and and I
always expect when I watch an assembly
to want to kill myself you know I mean
because basically you see
you see all the things you did wrong you
see what's not working it's the worst
version of the film ever is the assembly
and hopefully you know you just you know
that's just the way it works right and
so
um but it was just really they've done
this amazing feat of like putting
everything together really well and
and so
but that implies there's this version of
the film with all this stuff in it you
could sit and watch and I think that's
just not true it's
we got it down like we always wanted I
always wanted to make a two-hour movie
Star Wars is pretty much that and it's
like pacing wise is like spot on and so
I didn't want to like outstand my
welcome and do like a long film and and
I think it was there's a film critic in
the UK
he said Stanley Kubrick managed to tell
a story from the dawn of mankind until
we evolve into being a God in two hours
ten minutes so if you take longer
telling your story you're just not
trying hard enough and I've always like
took that to heart like it feels like
they kind of got a point
um
and so it was really a game of Jenga
like what can we remove from the film
and it not fall to pieces
um and and it was just trial and error
over like basically until the the clock
ran out and we got there I hopes but it
was um
it's a fascinating experience because
you show people the movie and they
uh we had a 2 hour 15 version of the
movie which we already loved
we played it to a bunch of people
Everyone disagreed like about what they
thought was right and wrong and then the
people the people who ran the test
screening said when that happens it
tends to mean it's too long
so we cut 15 minutes out and got it down
to two hours played it again and it did
way way better and there was no more
disagreements and it was a strange
lesson in how can you take things out we
love and it's still and then it'd be
better you know it didn't make sense but
apparently that's what happened so I
have so many follows but I have to go
I'm just gonna say I hope on the Blu-ray
the eventual Blu-ray you include a bunch
of deleted scenes or whatever because I
would love to see more in this world no
okay well yeah point taken we'll see
what happens next and that note uh good
luck with your career press conference
and thank you for everything thank you
no thank you